I've been through a trial a criminal
trial where I was a witness who
testified uh and made allegations in a
criminal matter before and that process
I think has
it helped me understand potentially why
some victims don't go forward uh the
process of
um being cross-examined and gaslit and
reliving over and over a really
traumatic experience is it really
destroys you and that then kind of
opened my eyes to why I kind of
understand why some women for the first
time it made me understand perhaps why
some people don't immediately go to law
enforcement however that that doesn't
mean that I support them that decades
later years later then they go
anonymously to the Press yeah I I got a
best I don't care I I don't play to this
emotional argument of oh it's so hard
and it's so emotional it you know it was
very difficult for people to do this